[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon équipe est une équipe jeune motivé
fiable et puis avec une diversité
d'origines socioprofessionnelles et puis
de tous les quartiers de la ville ils
sont engagés pour un projet au service
des plaisirs roi de tous les âges
donc on a une vraie équipe renouvelée à
la fois avec de l'expérience et de la
jeunesse
[Applaudissements]
alors le point phare c'est la vie nature
et la ville protectrice
on a pu le constater avec cette période
du cornât virus que les mentalités ont
énormément évolué et changé dans qu'au
niveau de la vie nature c'est quelque
chose que nous avions déjà engagé à
notre niveau dans notre corps notre
présentation de programmes avec un
développement massif des espaces verts
sur la collectivité la pratique des
vélos les écoquartiers et puis pour la
toupie protection si surtout la médecine
de proximité avec aussi la sécurité des
citoyens c'est indispensable
et puis sans oublier l'emploi et le
développement économique puisque
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que
véritablement c'est une attente aussi
après cette grande période de crise que
nous avons traversée tous ensemble
[Applaudissements]
l'ouverture de la mise en médical les
médecins nous les avons trouvés ils sont
là donc on va ouvrir cette maison
médicale qui vit qui s'appelle la ruche
à l'intérieur de l'hôpital dans un
premier temps avec aussi si vous me le
permettez parce qu'on est quand même
dans une continuité avec un service de
navettes interquartiers pour les seniors
et puis aussi une refonte importante des
tarifications qui sont en cours
actuellement pour accompagner aussi les
difficultés des familles ça me semble
aussi indispensable d'avoir cette
réflexion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]